hello it's me again okay so the other
day I got a comment from one of the
female Watchers of my videos or at least
the watcher of one of my videos and she
ultimately asked what the difference was
between girls who watched Twilight for
the guys in it and guys who watched
transformers 2 for Megan Fox and I just
had to do a video about this because the
answer is none whatsoever they're both
absolute [ __ ] reasons to watch movies
and I'll tell you why because people who
watch Twilight for Team Edward and Team
Jacob went to a movie to watch someone
they thought was fun to look at while
having to choke down horrible acting
within a horrible movie that sadly won't
be the last one of its series and people
who watch transformers 2 for Megan Fox
went to a movie to see someone they
thought was fun to look at while having
to choke down their horrible acting
within a horrible movie that sadly won't
be the last one of its franchise see no
difference the only difference might be
that these two actually might have more
estrogen than Megan Fox that and when
Twilight soccer-mom fans were drooling
over the teen weredog and new moon Megan
Fox was actually legal yes when new moon
was filmed Taylor Lautner was a 17 year
old boy
ladies spending money to see a shirtless
teenage boy is that a good idea
think of it this way if an adult man
stood in line to see Hannah Montana or
any other movie featuring the feature
heroin addict watch out Disney kids
would that be remotely normal no he
would be required by a judge to have a
sit down with just saying
and as for Megan Fox I understand that
she is actually really hot sorry ladies
I can only actually relate to the Megan
Fox thing guys we have that unstoppable
force called the Internet anything you
want to see anything at all it's just a
mouse-click away and it doesn't cost 10
bucks a ticket to see it well I guess
you can trust a lot more than that if
you're not smart about it so be smart
when looking for your porn
I mean Megan Fox pictures now I'm not
promoting porn I'm just a realist and
had probably promote that than a bad
Megan Fox movie probably because porn
has better acting and as for you women
if scrawny pale white guys just happened
to be your thing well it's a good thing
you found my channel oh yes I'm just
like Edward if Paul Pfeiffer from The
Wonder Years grew up and got mixed in a
vat with Edward zach braff Balki and
this guy and got sneezed on to YouTube
yeah it's pretty much about it but the
guys from Twilight are now all over 18
so good news ladies you're no longer
pedophiles but if you keep watching
those Twilight movies they're going to
keep making more and with the inevitable
birth of every Twilight movie comes the
inevitable after
birth of movies like remember me and the
same goes with us guys on the careers of
girls like Megan Fox we keep watching
and they'll keep making the power is
ours to stop it but as long as we keep
the cycle going it'll never change that
sounded more like a racism PSA than I
wanted it to and now for the Eclipse
trailer hey take a seat let's talk
[Music]